نريد أن نلفت انتباهك إلى
شيء آخر حدث في
مؤتمر البيت الأبيض في وقت سابق من ظهر هذا اليوم ، حيث
تم القبض على مستشار الأمن القومي جون بولتون ، حيث التقط مصورًا صورة
لهذه المفكرة التي كان يحملها
في غرفة الإحاطة و  إذا لاحظت
في هذا السطر الثاني أنه يقول 5000 جندي
إلى كولومبيا بشكل جيد في الدقائق العديدة الأخيرة فقط ، تمكن
منتج البيت الأبيض
كيفين ليبتاك من الحصول على بيان
من مسؤول في البيت الأبيض هنا
هذا البيان المختصر جدًا ردًا على
هذا السؤال حول ما  لقد قيل هذا
بشكل أساسي حيث قال
الرئيس إن جميع الخيارات مطروحة على الطاولة
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالوضع في
فنزويلا ، لذا فإن تطورًا مثيرًا للاهتمام
قد حدث نوعًا ما
في جميع رؤوسنا بعد ظهر هذا اليوم في
إحاطة البيت الأبيض.
لا أرى أنه من الصف الأول
غرفة الإحاطة ما كان مكتوبًا على
دفتر مستشاري الأمن القومي ، لكن
هذا كاد يبكي.  هناك عبارة
تقول إن هناك 5000 جندي في كولومبيا ، وأن البيت الأبيض
لم يقم بإسقاط ذلك لأنه من
المحتمل أن يكون خيارًا
للولايات المتحدة والتعامل مع هذه
الأزمة التي تتكشف في فنزويلا كما
تعلم ، ثم قالوا إنه قال إن جميع
الخيارات مطروحة على الطاولة
الخيار العسكري أيضًا مهم
جدًا مهم جدًا حقًا في عمل جيد.
شكرًا جزيلاً لجيم أكوستا